maroco super sain que l'on peut lui
suffire pour résister longtemps on s'est
pas vu c'est vrai à la rocco siffredi 42
ans 1300 films 4000 femmes plus ou moins
plus ou moins je n'ai pas vraiment vous
vous publiez vos mémoires c'est pascal
pitcho et ça s'appelle rocco par rocco
oui alors il ya un scoop c'est qu'il est
gradué tu vois laurent sur 24 cm voilà
je n'avais pas remarqué tout de suite
l'éditeur m'a dit un jour triste et je
vais lui donner l'idée de faire quelque
chose comme un signe livre lui me dit
c'est plus élégant comme ça à quelqu'un
il faut qu'il le trouve mais c'est pas
vraiment 24 23 et 1 cm avec un pointeur
objectif à presque 23 c'est la taille
vrai le 24 ça dépend de la fille 23 donc
oui ça grondait la fille parfois il va
jusqu'à maintenant
alors en tous les cas vous avez déclaré
rocco siffredi très peu de femmes ont
des problèmes avec les gros sexe au
moins pour moi c'était comme ça beaucoup
de fois da que je sortais mon sexe avons
une scène beaucoup de fois c'était au
[ __ ] mais mais après il ya une façon
d'apprendre à la mettre dedans après il
me demande pas de relève et donc c'était
c'était plus un jour agréable je les
adore mais il fait quand je suis né avec
tout ça mais c'est la vérité viendra
qu'au et ses soeurs
mais sinon on ne peut pas
racontée dans ce livre rocco siffredi
votre enfance à non c'est vrai qu'il ya
deux points comme très intéressant c'est
que vous êtes né sous le signe du
taureau et que votre grand père était
éleveur de taureaux reproducteurs oui le
signe du d'espérer une prédestination
évidente évidemment un mais vous étiez
enfant de coeur quand vous étiez petit
oui c'était plus ou moins une imposition
liées à la culture italienne donc ma
mère elle tenait beaucoup qui tous les
dimanches à l'église elle tenait
beaucoup qu'un de ses fils ses garçons 1
ça devient prêtre comme j'étais le plus
grand le plus haut et plus ou moins elle
elle aurait adoré que je deviens prête
mais malheureusement c'était pas
vraiment comme ça pour une fois on peut
plein dans l'écurie
alors quand je fais un bide j'ai ma
carte 10 à 3 ans la
[Musique]
première masturbation à l'âge de 10 ans
c'est peu tard ça
tous les temps d'aujourd'hui oui ouais
ah ça c'est le paradis là vous découvrez
évidemment ouais c'est autre chose la
vraie vie la vraie vie et votre mère qui
est en train de faire la lessive sur la
terrasse vous voit par la lucarne des
toilettes et vous vous rendez compte que
votre mère vous voit en train de vous
masturber effet que vous restiez deux
heures et c'est la vraie honte mais je
dois dire que j'ai eu vraiment une grand
grand grand grand mère c'est grâce à
elle que je suis où je suis aujourd'hui
c'est grâce à elle que parce qu'elle
elle m'a jamais fait pc-7 cette histoire
de rançon je suis sorti des toilettes je
m'attendais les fessiers je m'attendais
n'importe quoi elle m'a donné un regard
soit disant mon fils il a grandi mais
elle a pas vu lui-même et rauque
impression alors voilà donc l'été vous
êtes garçon de plage et là vous avez une
libido très très embarrassante parce
qu'il suffit vous voyez trois poils
pubiens qui dépasse d'un bikini de
parasols
non mais ça c'est ça c'est la réalité
mais c'est pire parce que je ne sais si
j'ai vécu je vécu toute mon adolescence
très très mal soi-disant avec des soldes
complexe parce qu'à l'époque on avait
des meilleurs très serré et je me
souviens qu'ils d'accord on m'appelle
santé une copine c'était enchanté et moi
j'avais une érection donc j'avais une
honte et terrifiant je me chantait
d'allos ou suivant 1 et les filles
comprenait pas pourquoi je lui parlais
dans le
désert et c'était vraiment très très mal
à l'aise cette histoire à l'époque
j'étais tellement masturber vois que
vous avez une cystite chronique
devraient être encore mais c'est vrai et
des ampoules terrible
tous ces histoires que vous il est que
vous lisez dans un de ses livres qui a
pas du tout la prétention d'être un
livre havrais un livre dont vous trouvez
quelque chose d'extrêmement littéraire
pas du tout parce que c'est moi que je
l'écris par rapport à plusieurs
problèmes c'est un premier jet
moi je trouve que c'est un livre très
intéressant justement parce qu'il est
vrai nom mais je peux vous raconter des
trucs extraordinaires les tournois de
branlette pendant que vous faites les
tomates brawn est il comme il arrive à
faire 11 éjaculation en six heures comme
c'est une norme mais vous saviez daleton
daleton moi je n'ai pas trop l'école je
faisais partie de ces garçons qui
étaient au dernier rebond et qui se
branler on regarde on la prof d'anglais
si vous voulez je faisais partie de
cette catégorie est donc je vais un ami
à moi umberto pour les johnny qui était
haut adour s'est passé les magazines on
se passait des histoires et ont organisé
les tournois de branlette donc qui
voulaient participer il n'allait pas
l'école 8h30 devant l'école en sortez et
on se représenter on allait en dessous
de retourner vous avez un pin est un
truc un cachet et ont passé des heures à
se branler mais c'est vrai que c'était
une une situation très naturel en europe
et entre mecs il faut je crois d'avoir
style eu le record de l'époque parce que
cette fois il ya personne qui sait une
en bronze éjaculation en six heures
c'est vrai qu' à l'époque c'était c'est
un jeu mais après c'est devenu un
problème lié au fait que je commence à
vous et je commençais à avoir
sérieusement des problèmes de brûlures
larry est donc plus je me masturbe et
plus à brûler et la façon d'y arriver la
brûlure s'était masturbé de plus dont
c'était un jeu vicieux alors après bon
fait vos premiers jobs vous êtes
manoeuvre ensuite vous engagé dans la
marine et puis un jour de uma vous
débarquez à paris chez votre frère
armando à mende voilà qui est patron
d'un restaurant da juillet
casa nostra j'ai dit ces temps là dans
un premier temps beaucoup de conquêtes
beaucoup de conquêtes féminines oui à
idées je sais j'ai fait avec cliente du
restaurant qui n'est qu'habiter au
dessus de ce seuil
et puis à 20 ans vous découvrez un club
échangiste qui s'appelle chez denise
alors à son succès au 106 maintenant
c'est au 41ème enfin c'est ce qu'on aime
toujours son sujet
l'un d'eux est tous les soirs après le
boulot vous y allez partout un sens
c'est un petit peu la coqueluche de cet
endroit ça faisait longtemps avant que
j'avais demandé à mon fernando est ce
que tu connais quelqu'un qui fait des
films pour l'homme a dit m tfou de quoi
tu cherches mais à l'époque qui avait
pas il n'y avait pas la vidéo il y avait
que le cinéma en 35 cm dont 35 cm
excusez-moi fin de sa vie il animait
35 mm et malheureusement et jeudi il y
avait aucun endroit où je pouvais
rentrer dedans donc par rapport à tout
ça par rapport à tout ça l'histoire
c'est que mon frère ne pouvait pas
m'aider le seul endroit qui jamais
intéressé les boîtes échangistes
mais tu te fais est pas rentré à
l'époque tout seul il faut y aller
accompagné par une fille c'est toujours
pareil donc je connaissais les filets
gamine de 18 ans j'avais 19 ans donc je
connaissais dégâts 1017 sais je
m'appelle je vais pas lui demander ce
que tu m'accompagnes des bois de changer
selon maher en prend pour un fou donc
c'était la femme de 40 ans je connais
belle femme de 40 ans je sois avec
finalement en termine au lit commun je
voulais et je les pose la question de ce
suite à presles mais dis donc mettez
foule commence à rire après unis mais
pourquoi elle est dans un endroit comme
ça la réalité c'est que je voulais voir
qu'est ce qui se passe dans ces endroits
et je dois avouer qui aida que je suis
rentré qui m'ont fait rentrer jesson
kinert très familière
non mais c'est vrai quelque chose à
laquelle j'ai senti chez toi
et à l'aise dans vos chansons terenez
mais
c'est la réalité je me sens calais senti
chez toi jusqu'au jour où tu rencontres
au 106 super sexe un super c'est que
c'est un type dont tu étais fan quand tu
étais jeune parce qu'il y avait tous les
journaux et une personne c'était le
délire au pour quelqu'un ici thierry
charpentier qu'un ici pour
excuser moi ça va bien ça veut dire
quelqu'un de très simple c'est une star
du porno italien c'est tout pourri soit
l'argentine chaussures noires
il s'appelle gabriel et pommes telle au
diabète continent dans lequel il a
toujours dit qu'il est italien il est
français je sais qu'il est très bien
français bon l'histoire c'est une autre
c'est que pour moi le voir en vrai après
m'être masturber milliers de fois avec
sa figure c'était quelque chose
d'incroyable donc le voir en vrai ils
étaient accompagnés par do belle femme
me dit avec son gros cigare il me fais
toi ta grosse bille toi tu le baise tout
aux médias je réponds ça me plaît mais
l'effet voir qu'est ce tu sais faire il
m'a passé les 12 m en face de 200
personnes je suis restée 12 heures là je
me suis amusé les jeunes apej été
mauvais tout cela comment il a trouvé du
travail sont tous que le sait une
audition quoi sans disposition tout à
fait c est chez gabriel qui te présente
à marc dorcel et voilà comment la
carrière à quatre jours de tournage en
photo il faut dire que j'ai débuté avec
la kinect je tiens à dire parce que ça
reste la plus belle actrice française
s'est
engagée nous rappelle régine
c'est
la team est joli cela c est vrai
la plus belle prononce heure française
que j'aie jamais connue je débutais avec
la plus belle c'est la mairie morro do
on s'était vraiment impossible à coucher
avec je peux dire à baiser parce que là
alors ce qui est terrible c'est que le
premier jour tu as tellement peur de
jouir tout de suite qu avant le premier
tournage tu vas te masturber dans les
chiottes oui il a une facilité à se
masturber
regarde pas ses mains sur la table mais
fut avait à l'époque il faut des choses
il faut dire vraiment les choses un
moment là c'est un moment très important
de ma carrière j'ouvre la porte de cet
appartement 15e arrondissement et je me
trouve hindisheim nana qui se promènent
à droite à gauche avec des porte
jarretelles de talons aiguilles mon
cerveau il explose et je suis rentré
avec un pied dans un autre univers et je
me suis dit mon ma tête allait exploser
je suis parti aux toilettes à me branler
parce que j'étais sur les faire mauvaise
figure bien si je le fais quand même
parce que c'était trop fort les émotions
c'est être autre force pas facile les
tournages au début parce que les
connexions sont jaloux ils
allaient à l'époque c'était beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus malin c'était il y en
avait un je me souviens la grand léjon
l'appeler jean pierre armand moi je suis
pas tombé sur lui je suis tombé sur
andré venus qui est il m'a pas gâté non
plus parce que il était moi j'étais
débuts avec les douches et les deux
filles étaient prêtes à poils très très
très joli il y avait une blonde
française et notre chaîne donc andré
vino il était à genoux et se masturber
pour se préparer moi je t'ai en érection
dont les filles je n'avais pas besoin de
me filmer parce que la vision ça suffit
et je me disais mais pourquoi ils se
masturbent il est fou donc à partir de
là il me dit qu'au faîte au dessous
c'est jade et fais-toi dessous c'est moi
et mes mélanges
mais il m'a piégé parce que tout d'un
coup d'accueil à lui pas me tenais je
recule avant que la caméra par dix
élèves et des vases et on y va on y va
maintenant on y va moi je reste comme un
tuyau mais l'histoire vraie et qui m'a
tellement piégée qui m'a il m'a
complètement foutu à l'heure donc je
suis parti au bar à prendre trois momies
pour me calmer je dois me faire
recommencer mais c'était j'ai eu de la
chance à l'époque parce que quand on
travaille le premier jour oui je me suis
dit je me suis dit vraiment vous pouviez
pas imaginé dans ma tête que cet espace
parce que je me disais j'ai tout foutu à
l'heure je me suis fait piéger commun
comme un gamin ne voit pas facile à
l'époque parce qu'un jour présent tu
racontes tu tombes sur alicia monnaie ah
ouais ça c'est un mauvais sexuellement
l'habite après ap après m'avoir péter
dans la future
centrale me more l'habite après m'avoir
péter de la figure c'est ces journées
terribles les films comiques on le fait
français semblant là c'était vrai saturé
mois tiens c'était autre chose
c'était facile tous les jours le cinéma
il tourne et 25 jours par mois en plus
il n'y avait pas de là c'était du boulot
mais il n'est pas en quoi il y avait une
époque avec terry 0 ce qui peut-être
quelqu'un l'a connaît pour moi c'était
la plus grande pendant ces européens
c'était vraiment la fille qui a été
prêté pendant huit heures jamais demandé
dès l'aube ils oublient fico rien les
actrices américaines s arrêtait pas
l'ubs please love me please ouattara qui
se dessine dans l'oubli elle rien nous
on y aller on à l'infini tout lubrifié
comme noël c'était à haute ou l'oubli
fier devant alors un moment recours vous
mettez votre vie d'acteur entre
parenthèses parce que vous rencontrez
tina oui dont vous tombez très amoureux
et là avec elsa vit une relation
sexuelle très violente un très belle et
très fort très passionné jusqu'au moment
où gsl
celle qui m'a initié dans une sexualité
différente traité un peu maso je crois
qu'on peut le dire n'ont peut-être très
fort oui parce que je me suis vingt fois
pendant l été de plus en plus il avait
de plus en plus envie pendant que je la
prends que je une fois je me souviens je
répondais je l'appréhendais mais je
connaissais pas tout ça il m'a giflé je
lui remets j'ai fait les jeux cultes et
là un orgasme et de travail et à partir
de là à partir de là c'est devenu un peu
bizarre parce qu'elle n'arrêtait pas de
me dire à chaque fois qu'on avait un
problème de toute façon la seule chose
que tu ce faire cette bct pantalon et je
lui dit une femme une fois je n'accepte
1 à la prochaine fois je l'accepterais
pas parce que j'ai laissé mon boulot
pour toi ouais et donc pour regarder ça
que j'étais mannequin j'essayais soit
dix ans c'est un métier trop difficile
pour moi parce que pour mon corps il
n'est pas fait pour être mannequin
d'inde à cette situation j'allais très
mal où vivait vraiment au mois après je
me suis bien adapté ne manger des
spaghettis en blanc pendant un mois
parce qu'on n'avait pas de sous c'était
une vie mais on était content je veux
pas dire autre chose être amoureux
n'avoir pas de soucis mauvais c'est bien
c'est super mais c'est pas bien contre
le feu contre le feu 6 et 1 1 il ya qui
du centre que querrey je me suis en vers
la fin je lui fais une connerie je fais
quelque chose de mauvais et vers elle
elle m'a plus laisser que je la touche
pendant six mois donc elles passées à
lire son livre et moi je me branle et
aux toilettes on regarde on est le
secrétaire qu'il a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup j'ai continué
et à la porte des toilettes c'est pas
très important un des salons et même
dans les films beaucoup de beaucoup de
fois c'est pas ça même le vin film
ensuite vous reprenez votre travail de
porno star c'est le grand succès aux
états unis et puis aussi la jalousie
parce que vous devenez une espèce
d'icône alors on raconte les pires
conneries sur vous on dit que vous êtes
violents et les actrices ce lundi xavier
le sydam enfin rien n'y fait vous êtes
une énorme star rien ne vous atteint et
alors chez votre mère en italie il ya
des gens qui viennent les présents qui
viennent en procession voir sa mère
c'est quand même la mère de rocco
siffredi labarde saône et alors ça mais
là elle dit attendez vous êtes gentil
j'ai fait une [ __ ] comme ça ils ont fait
ce qu'il veut j'ai eu la chance parce
que je suis un garçon ce jour était une
fille sur le titre est difficile mon
père m'a toujours dit
sur le fait qu'une quête non non non moi
passer pour une fille aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ça peut mais mais jeudi en
italie la mentalité bien sûr si tu es un
homme mon père il m'a toujours des tubes
s10 fille super mais ne me fait pas
attendre que tout chamekh donc tu veut
s'éviter un peu comme ça va alors à 40
ans vous arrêter pour plusieurs raisons
malheureusement parce qu'il ma
personnalité d'italiens ressort à 40 ans
avec mes gosses qui grandissent ma femme
et qui pendant 13 ans elle a été
toujours là disponibles et m'a toujours
laissé ces contrats signés vas-y
t'inquiète pas il ya aucun problème donc
quand on a cet gens de des situations
familières ça fait que deux peut-être ma
mentalité italienne même si je vais
presser à l'intérieur de moi reçoit dix
mois est-ce que c'est pas aussi des
problèmes de prostate qui vous ont amené
à vous arrêtez pas du tout parce que ça
fait dix ans que je n'aime pas dormir
une nuit entière j'ai besoin de me lever
pour aller uriner donc c'est pas
admettre dans ça fait dix ans que je ne
sais pas un cellier je pense la prostate
a été trop sollicité à mon oui parce que
quand on fait 25 jours par mois avec
d'autres et jacques par jour c'est bien
sûr évident que en sollicite trop la
prostate avec le dois aussi c'est à dire
en dessous les
oui comme vous dites bien sûr aux vignes
les roubignoles testicules les
testicules donc on pousse on pousse et
pour faire sortir parfois du sperme qui
à la limite ça ressemble plus à de l'eau
minérale près
ccc on dirait que les gens croient pas
mais c'est vraiment comme ça 21 jours
par mois aux 25 jours par mois 2 3
orgasme peugeot sa fait beaucoup un
[Musique]
certain nombre de mails de
téléspectateurs
on pense à quoi pour bandés pendant des
heures
moi je peux vous dire à quoi je pense
pour pas éjaculer pendant deux ans parce
que parfois ça m'arrive de tourner avec
des filles qui sont sublimes trop belle
un terme entre bell et l'a donc au début
de ma carrière je me suis bien sûr des
piscines partout je faisais semblant
d'avoir un caillou je faisais au [ __ ]
mais qu'est ce qu'il y a pour se dire
habite parce que sinon j'allais juguler
parce qu'elle bougeait trop bien ça
m'arrive aussi avec ma femme donc je
veux dire l'important c'est pas paniquer
tu la sors tu embrasses à la fille tu
fais autre chose ça descend la pression
tu recommences après et et tu retrouvé
tous rétablis la pression et peinture
bouche pendant 12 heures et aucun
problème avec ça marche toujours est-ce
qu'on peut réussir dans le porno sont
couchés
bien sûr que oui c'est déjà c'est déjà
pas mal je dis ça vous fait quoi que
tout le monde se branle de vos films ça
me fait plaisir en tant que spécialiste
roku sait combien le bon nombre pour une
partouze ça dépend ça peut être aussi
dit persan ça peut être amusant personne
c'est bien oui mais il faut des gens
bien il faut pas des gens qui se mêle à
dormir
quand vous étiez une star du x est ce
que vous rameniez du boulot à la maison
le soir on en parlait de ça ce matin
avec ma femme elle m'a dit [ __ ] t'as
changé depuis que je te connais au début
c'était vraiment mécano un vainqueur
c'est ma femme qui lit des différentes
il fait des pâtes qu'il ya double peigne
al arabia
alors coup c'est catherine breillat qui
vous a donné votre premier rôle dans le
cinéma traditionnel vous l'avez
remercier comment
peut-être vraiment sincèrement j'aurais
dû la remercier mieux mais parce qu'elle
est elle a vraiment elle m'a donné une
grande chance de connaître qu'est-ce que
c'était le vrai cinéma donc catherine
bréard merci merci merci c'est tout mais
merci c'est tout qu'est-ce que je fasse
je
remercie cette demande toujours comment
vivent les vieux acteurs qui ont fait du
porno une double pénétration c'est
combien de points de retraite
si je suis prêt calculé ça j'aurai
beaucoup de retraités nous voulons c'est
trois points - oui c'est ça ouais c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui roque aussi une fois
par semaine le samedi soir dans la
position du missionnaire et après bastin
pas du tout vrai j'ai dit j'ai dit ça
m'arrive ne pas le faire pendant une
semaine mais ça m'arrive de le faire
aussi une semaine tous les jours
c'est chez pascale petit aux éditions
évidemment je demande un peu complexé on
a un peu jaloux par rapport à vous
recommandons qu'on va faire une
interview même rocco
est-ce que même rocco aimerait avoir un
sexe plus grands parfois écouté des mais
bon je n'ai vu quelqu'un d'américains
qui a débarqué vraiment avec des 30 cm x
et donc je me suis sentie petty mais ça
va bien ça va je suis content de ça que
j'avais combien est-ce que même rocco a
du mal à bander parfois oui est-ce que
même rocco a du mal à revendre et
parfois plutôt ça est-ce que même rocco
a déjà pensé que sa femme simulaient
jamais est-ce que même rocco a déjà
galéré pour séduire une fille oui
beaucoup de fois est-ce que même rocco a
déjà pris des râteaux il a deux manches
déjà beaucoup de fois beaucoup de fous
est-ce que même rocco s'est déjà fait
traiter de petit beat
psychologiquement oui est-ce que même
rocco a déjà pensé qu'ils avaient pas
que le cul dans la vie beaucoup de fois
c'est difficile est-ce que même rocco
pense que le plus important c'est la
tendresse oui mais aussi avec le reste
avec la double peine non mais je pense
moi je pense que latendresse va avec le
reste il faut jamais être dur sans
l'attendre mais son don des bisous
avancer beaucoup mieux c'est le secret
de m corner voilà est-ce que même
récompense que des films x ont une
influence néfaste
moi je pense que comme toulouse tous les
autres choses de la vie la télé les jeux
tout ça qu'on nous montre toute la
journée c'est au même niveau je ne
pensais jamais que la pornographie c'est
éducatif éducatif mais aussi le
contraire donc je ris gdg des déjections
peu touché à la main j'ai des gens qui
me faire mal à la rue on me dit merci
d'exister moi j'ai [ __ ] je suis pas
dieu mais il me dit comme cela est un
jeu d autres qui me disent mais qu'est
ce que vous faites qu'est ce que vous
faites qu'est ce que vous faites si
j'allais 2 qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
je vous dise ouais est-ce que même rocco
se dit parfois qu'il est anormal
beaucoup de fois
j'ai pascal pessiot édition
la
carte cadeau vous gagnez folle nuit
d'amour et de sexe débridé avec béatrice
ardisson
je sais pas dit celle
qui sait c'est la maman de mon humeur
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu